for years marvel fans have asked for a
solo movie centered on black widow
she's appeared as a supporting character
or popped up in a cameo in iron man 2
the avengers
captain america the winter soldier
avengers age of ultron
captain marvel captain america civil war
avengers infinity war
and avengers end game up until this
point she's been the superhero
equivalent of a bridesmaid without ever
being a bride
that all changed on july 9th when black
widow finally got the solo adventure she
so richly deserves the movie
accomplished shares a great deal within
its 134 minute run time
it proves natasha can save the day even
without superhuman powers
it gives her death and avengers end game
more meaning by showing how much her
found family within the avengers meant
to her and it introduces a ton of fun
new characters that have the potential
to pop up in other marvel projects
if the black widow post credits scene is
any indication natasha's sister figure
elena bolova will be seen again
but we also hope this film isn't the
last time we see alexi shostakov aka the
red guardian
he's effectively the russian version of
captain america who believes he's on
equal footing with steve rogers and is
essentially the walking embodiment of
the cold war plus he has more than a few
tattoos to show off his heritage when
natasha and elena break alexia out of
prison
we get a good look at the various
tattoos he's acquired over the years
one of these will only make sense if you
can read russian on alexis bicep you
might notice two roses ain't underneath
the flowers are a couple of russian
words
translated into english these words are
actually the names natasha and elena
respectively
this shows that all of these years later
alexi always remembered the two girls
who pretended to be his daughters
while they lived in the united states
it's a vital easter egg because alexi
natasha elena and melina vastakov
weren't a biological family
they were put together by villainous
forces to spy on americans
and after they escaped from ohio they
didn't see each other again until the
events of black widow it would be easy
to assume alexi didn't form an emotional
attachment to his faux daughters
but as his tattoo attests he always
carried a part of them with him
if you look carefully you may notice
that in addition to the rose tattoo for
his daughters
he also has one of his wife molina you
have to look on his left hand side to
his neck
there's an image of a woman sporting a
bob haircut and there's no doubt about
it that he's memorialized molina on his
skin
out of all the tattoos featured on
alexi's body actor david harbour has
said that molina's portrait holds a
special place in his heart
as he told variety that was probably my
favorite one because i love rachel vice
that's likely a big reason why when they
finally reunite they flirt with each
other like old high school sweethearts
hopefully the two rekindled their
relationship when they went off together
at the end of the movie
it would be awfully awkward if alexi
dated other women on the outside
and had to explain why he has rachel
weiss's face on his shoulder
you might have also noticed the red
guardian has writing on his knuckles
no he's not a hell's angels member with
love and hate on his hands
if you pay attention you may realize
what he actually has written across his
fingers is karl marx
marx was a philosopher best known for
writing the communist manifesto
and his ideas played a significant role
in the formation of the 20th century
russian revolution
it appears marx's ideology is alive and
well in whatever prison alexey was
locked up in for so many years
as a symbol of the soviet union it makes
sense for alexi to have tattoos
celebrating russia's history and that's
not even the only one he has on his body
in an interview with inverse actor david
harbour mentioned
there's other stuff that's personal
stuff that's communist he has a tattoo
of lenin on his belly
i don't know if you see it the red
guardian getting vladimir lenin tattooed
on his body and having karl marx's name
on his hands
is basically the equivalent of captain
america getting a giant tattoo of a bald
eagle on his chest
and having his knuckles read john jay we
suppose that option is still available
for john walker to do
black widow is now available to watch in
theaters and on disney plus
with premiere access check out one of
our newest videos right here plus
even more looper videos about your
favorite tv shows and movies are coming
soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss
a single one